wir können lange drüber reden fakt ist
ich glaube nicht dass Waffenlieferungen
im Krieg ähm beenden am Sanktion kann
man darüber reden ich glaube nur die
Sanktion haben uns mehr geschadet der
westlichen Welt als sie Russland
geschadet haben und die Zahlen anschaut
sehe ich einfach rekordsteuereinnahmen
Rekord Umsätze mit Öl Gas und anderen
Rohstoffen die Russland gerade verbuchen
dann auch eins zu eins wieder eine
Kriegswirtschaft in finanzieren kann das
ist Russland was sie in der beschreiben
das höre ich also deutlich anders also
da kommt glaube
158 Milliarden im zweiten Quartal aber
das Einnahmen die russische Wirtschaft
getroffen wurde von den Sanktionen das
stimmt also stimmt definitiv Fakt es ist
ja nicht so als hätte die russische
Wirtschaft der ging es jetzt besser als
vor den Sand zu das stimmt nicht wir
wurden selbstverständlich auch getroffen
aber da gehe ich hier auch mit dass die
russische Wirtschaft natürlich schon
leidet und es gibt auch Experten die
sagen es wird länger dauern bis die in
Gänze wirken die Sanktionen